[Applause]
[Music]
rock'n'roll star
[Applause]
wait ladies and gentlemen her rehab is
taking that's right let's try somebody
else in the red chair okay quick let's
even get a story
hello a nice lady what's your name
Jessica Jessica conclude Queenie here
Jessica bye then
she's so sweet she's French she's
adorable
atomic she's French she said didn't she
say like Pathan she's pops
[Applause]
okay can you ever go in the chair okay
go you go and do that again
okay where's the chair it's part of that
man there follow-up on that
okay but hurry we've got homes to go to
this is the best time I've ever had on
the talk show
[Applause]
yeah I think it's the champagne on the
hose
okay who's up next hi hi how are you hi
I just like to say that I think Matt
Damon is really amazing in the fourth
[Applause]
[Music]
give me a hug
and I said that I do my own makeup but I
can tell you and real diva would never
do her own makeup that part is it also
ridiculous